- [Voiceover] Many videos ago,
we first looked at the idea
of representing a periodic function
as a set of weighted cosines and sines,
as a sum,
as the infinite sum of
weighted cosines and sines,
and then we did some work in order to
get some basics in terms
of some of these integrals
which we then started to
use to derive formulas
for the various coefficients,
and we are almost there.
We have figured out a
formula for a sub zero.
We've figured out a coefficient
in general for any of the
coefficients on the cosines,
and now, let's figure
out a way to figure out
the coefficients on the sines.
So, how can we do that?
Well, we're going to use
a very similar technique
that we did to figure out
the formula for a sub n.
What we're going to do is multiply
both sides of this
equation right over here
by sine of nt.
So let's do that.
So, sine of nt,
and so, if we multiply the
right-hand side by sine of nt,
that means we're going
to multiply every one of
the infinite terms by sine of nt,
so sine of nt,
sine of nt,
I think you,
well, this is always a
little time consuming,
but I'll get there,
sine of nt,
and of course there is
these dot, dot, dot's,
so we're just showing in general,
we're taking each of the,
each of these terms and
multiplying them by sine of nt.
We'll do it for all of the terms.
We'll keep on doing
this, on and on forever,
for an infinite number of terms.
Well, now let's take the
integral of both sides
of this equation,
the definite integral from zero to 2 pi,
and once again, I'm picking
that interval because 2 pi
is the period of the periodic
function that we care about,
and everything else that I've been doing
has been over that interval of 2 pi,
so I'll just keep focusing in on that,
so from zero to 2 pi dt,
and I could say the integral
of this whole thing,
but we know that the integral
of a sum of a bunch of things
is also the same thing as
the sum of the integrals
and we also know that we can
take these constant multipliers
of expressions outside of integrals
and so this is going to be equal to,
if I take the integral
of the right-hand side,
the definite integral is
going to be from zero to 2 pi,
dt.
Zero to 2 pi, dt.
We're almost there.
And zero to 2 pi, dt,
and I would be doing this
for every term in this Fourier expansion.
Now, this is where some
of that integration work
is going to be valuable.
We've already shown that
sine of the definite integral
from zero to 2 pi of sine of nt, dt
is going to be equal to zero for n being
any integer.
So we saw that,
we saw that right over there,
so that tells us
that that term is going to be zero,
so that's going to be equal to zero
and we also know that when
we take a cosine of something
times t,
times the sine of something times t,
where these are integers,
and we take that definite integral,
we know that that's going to be zero,
so all of those are going to be zero,
and we also know that
when you take the sine
of two different non,
two different coefficients right over,
or sine of some integer
coefficient times t
times sine of some other
integer coefficient times t,
that these are also going
to be equal to zero.
We saw that,
we saw that right over here.
That is this property
and so, really, all you're left with,
the only one that does not become zero
is this term right over here,
where it's sine of nt times sine of nt,
and what is that going to be equal to?
Well, this, inside of the integral,
that's the same thing.
Let me do this in a different
color, since I'm using orange
to cross out everything
that ends up becoming zero,
so that is the same thing
as the definite integral
from zero to 2 pi of
sine-squared of nt, dt,
and I'll do the,
or the dt is still there
so I'm just replacing
the blue stuff with
the sine-squared of nt,
and we know what that's going to be.
We know that when the coefficient on the t
is a non-zero integer,
that this is going to result in pi.
So we know that
all of this stuff right over here,
we'll do that in a different color,
all of,
we know that all of this
stuff is going to evaluate,
or actually we should
say, all of this stuff
is going to become pi,
so we know that b sub n times
pi is going to be equal to
this definite integral.
Or, we could write,
let me write it this way,
b sub n times pi is equal to,
'cause everything else
ends up becoming zero,
is going to be equal to zero,
the definite integral from zero to 2 pi.
I'll put my dt out here,
of f of t,
f of t times sine of nt,
sine of nt,
dt, and so we can then
divide both sides by,
divide both sides by pi
and we get a little bit of a drum roll,
we get b sub n,
actually, I could write that,
I'll write that in that same blue color,
we get b sub n,
I'll do it actually right here,
b sub n is going to be equal to
1 over pi times the definite integral
from zero to 2 pi,
zero to 2 pi,
we have our dt here,
you have your f of t here,
and then you have your sine,
sine nt,
so once again, that was pretty
straight forward now that
we knew these,
these properties of integrals
so we knew how to evaluate these integrals
that are,
definite integrals that
are taking a cosine or sine
or products of cosines and sines.
And using these three formulas,
we can now attempt to find
the Fourier expansion,
the Fourier series,
find the coefficients for our square wave.